[Applaus]
[Musik]
Ich werde die Frage nicht beantworten,
weil die Frage ist,
hören Sie, wer auf Ihrer Liste steht, Joe, das ist
auf YouTube,
meine Herren, ich denke, das ist
der Präsident, der keinen Plan hat  Er hat nichts gesagt
,
was er wusste, bis in den
Februar hinein, wie ernst diese
Krise war, er wusste, dass es eine tödliche
Krankheit war,
was er getan hätte, wenn wir
auf Sie gehört hätten,
das Land wäre weit offen gelassen worden
, Millionen von Menschen hätten es getan  sind
nicht zweihunderttausend gestorben, und eine person
ist zu viel, es ist chinas schuld, es
hätte nie passieren dürfen
[musik]
ich hoffe, es wird eine faire wahl,
wenn es eine faire
wahl ist, bin ich 100 an bord, aber wenn ich zehntausende sehe
Stimmzettel werden manipuliert, da
kann ich nicht mitmachen,
also hier ist der Deal